bonjour à toutes et à tous le
tricératops n'existe pas voilà la phrase
qui aujourd'hui fait s'emballer les
réseaux sociaux le palais aux tubes la
paléo sphère est en feu après cette
intervention de max birds sur france
inter dont je vous mettrais la vidéo
dans la description c'est une toute
petite intervention de quelques minutes
vous pouvez aller la voir si vous ne
l'avez pas déjà vu et vous verrez que
max beurre 10 déclarent donc pour
provocative mans j'ai envie de dire pour
attiser la curiosité il dit le
tricératops n'existe pas et puis ensuite
il nous parle des fameuses recherche de
jack corner et de son équipe qui
démontreraient que le tricératops n'est
en fait qu'un juvénile de torosaurus
alors ça fait plaisir d'entendre ça sur
les ondes à des heures de grande écoute
mais ça a fait ça va énerver beaucoup de
gens parce que ben beaucoup de gens se
disent que ce n'est pas vrai et la vraie
question c'est est-ce que c'est vrai ou
est-ce que c'est pas vrai finalement
cette histoire de deux torosaurus qui
serait en fait un adulte de tricératops
et du coup tricératops n'existerait pas
donc déjà commençons par dire d'où ça
vient cette idée que tricératops ce
serait un juvénile de torosaurus et ben
ça vient tout simplement du fait que
tricératops et torosaurus on les
retrouve à peu près au même endroit et
au même moment donc fin du crétacé en
amérique du nord et tricératops on
trouve beaucoup beaucoup de juvéniles et
on en trouve beaucoup d'individus en
général tricératops quasiment tous les
ans dans découvre des nouveaux alors que
torosaurus lui est extrêmement rare il
est extrêmement rare il est aussi
beaucoup plus gros donc déjà ça ça peut
commencer à vous mettre la puce à
l'oreille et ça a mis la puce à
l'oreille donc de dja corner et de son
équipe puisque cette idée vient du
fameux paléontologues des corners celui
qui comme le rappelle max bird dans sa
vidéo était le conseiller scientifique
sujet sur jurassic park et la principale
aspiration pour le look de alan grant
donc ce fameux jack warner et son équipe
puisqu'il n'est pas tout seul sur là
dessus quand même eh bien ils ont
proposé que peut-être en fait torosaurus
c'était la forme adulte de tricératops
pour expliquer justement qu'on ne
trouvait pas de juvéniles de torosaurus
et qu'à côté de ça on trouvait
énormément de juvéniles de tricératops
et pour tester cette hypothèse ils ont
fait des sections dans le dans le crâne
de tricératops et notamment dans la
collerette et ils ont constaté que dans
lé crâne de tricératops
on voit des signes de croissance évident
qu'on ne trouve pas chez les spécimens
de torosaurus et donc ça pour eux c'est
le signe que les tricératops sont en
fait des juvéniles
alors que torosaurus et un adulte donc
et huskies ont proposé c'est que ba
tricératops est le juvénile de
torosaurus la subtilité est importante
vous allez le voir dire que tricératops
et un juvénile ça veut pas forcément
dire que c'est un juvénile de torosaurus
ça veut peut-être dire qu'on a juste
jamais trouvé d'individus complètement
adultes de tricératops
donc voilà ça c'est une grosse subtilité
très importante et elle est très
importante pour comprendre une chose une
chose essentielle c'est que qu'on
prétende que torosaurus est ou pas un
adulte de tricératops
les deux hypothèses sont quasiment
invérifiable ce sont deux hypothèses qui
sont quasiment nom est stable pourquoi
pas parce que si vous trouvez une forme
qui est intermédiaire entre tricératops
et torosaurus vous pouvez tout aussi
bien l'interpréter comme étant un
juvénile intermédiaire donc dans sa
croissance entre tricératops ou
torosaurus ou alors vous pouvez tout
aussi bien l'interpréter comme étant le
juvénile d'une autre espèce
c'est pas ça peut être ça peut être à la
fois un signal aux tons génique ou à
signal phylogénétique en fonction de
comment vous l'interprétez donc ça peut
être ou un jus mesnil ou alors une autre
espèce et les différences morphologiques
pourront être interprété des deux façons
divers différentes soient cédés des
différences morphologiques due à la
croissance soient ses différences
morphologiques dû au fait que c'est une
espèce différente
et puis si on arrivait par exemple à
trouver un juvénile supposé de
torosaurus et bâle les opposants à cette
théorie pourrait dire oui il s'agit d'un
juvénile
ça ressemble à tord aux russes mais
c'est pas forcément torosaurus et donc
on tourne en rond et ça fait des années
et des années que le débat comme ça
tourne en rond parce que à chaque fois
que l'un des camps avance une hypothèse
avec des preuves
eh bien les mêmes preuves peuvent être
retournés comme des chaussettes et
interprétée dans l'autre sens par
l'autre camp donc ça c'est là où on s'en
tient le débat à l'heure actuelle et
j'ai envie de dire l'erreur de max birds
c'est pas d'avoir haussé pas tant
d'avoir parlé de ce sujet que de l'avoir
présenté comme étant factuel
c'est à dire qu'il a présenté sa comme
étant une chose une chose tout à fait
établi que tricératops est un juvénile
de torosaurus il l'aurait dû je pense
parler du débat il y aurait dû dire
qu'il y avait un gros gros débat et j'ai
même envie de dire qu'à ce niveau là le
débat il n'est pas chaud il est
bouillant il est encore sur le feu la
casserole elle est là et elle bout et ça
s'agite et ça secoue s voilà sais c'est
pas quelque chose qui ait résolu du tout
la sphère torosaurus tricératops loin de
là mais on ne va quand même pas jeter la
première pierre max bird pour avoir
parlé de paléontologie sur france inter
il ya un moment où pour pouvoir
intéresser les gens à la paléontologie
faut aussi savoir donner des
informations qui sont clinquante et là
il s'est servi juste d'un fun fact d'un
fan fact sur la paléontologie pour
pouvoir parler de paléontologie à une
heure de grande écoute sur une grande
chaîne radio donc on va pas non plus
reprocher aux gens de parler de
paléontologie
la seule chose qu'on pourrait lui
reprocher basse et comme je les dis de
ne pas avoir présenté qu'il y avait un
débat et encore je crois qu'il le fait
mais très rapidement faudrait revoir la
vidéo dans le détail mais bref c'est
assez contesté et peut-être que ça
aurait mérité d'être mieux mentionné de
passer un peu plus de temps sur le fait
que c'était contestées mais comme je les
dis voilà c'est une chronique de
seulement quelques minutes on peut pas
tout caser on peut pas tout caser voilà
vous avez quand même entendu parler d'un
débat entre spécialistes sur france
inter donc on va pas non plus voilà
comme je dis jeter la première pierre à
nax bird pour ça il évoque par exemple
aussi le cas de stiggy moloch est passé
pas qui c'est fallows or donc stiggy
moloch qui serait le juvénile depaquit
céphale aux orres encore une hypothèse
défendue par l'équipe de jack corner
stiggy moloch et pas qui c'est fallows
or c'est encore plus dur de dire s'il ya
débat puisque au final
ya tellement peu de spécimens que c'est
presque impossible de résoudre le débat
on va vous dire que ben oui mais on a
trouvé des juvéniles depaquit céphale
aux ors et il ressemble bel et bien à
stiggy moloch oui mais enfin ça veut pas
pour autant dire que les stiggy moloch
sont pas des juvéniles d'une autre
espèce
voilà et c'est les mêmes arguments en
fait c'est le même cercle vicieux qui ce
qu'ils recommencent à chaque fois et
encore une fois la défense de mike bird
il parle de nano tyrannus et de
tyrannosaurus donc nano tyrannus qui
serait le juvénile de tyrannosaurus et
bah ça c'est pareil c'est un débat qui
est très très loin d'être finie encore
tout récemment donc le 15 septembre 2020
a été publié une réponse à l'article qui
prétendait m le clou définitive dans le
cercueil de nano tyrannus donc il ya un
article qui a été publié en janvier 2020
donc en janvier de cette année qui
disait ça y est c'est bon on a les
preuves que nano tyrannus c'est un
juvénile de tyrannosaurus ils ont fait
des coupes histologiques pour voir les
cercles de croissance à l'intérieur des
eaux
ils ont comparé à tyrannosaurus et hip
ils ont dit ça y est c'est fini
fin du jeu tyrannosaurus nano tyrannus
c'est la même chose et là 15 septembre
de cette année bim encore une réponse
publiée
je vous mettrai le lien dans la
description une équipe composée des
paléontologues du black hills institute
avant de continuer faut que je précise
le black hills institute ce n'est pas un
institut de recherche donc ce n'est pas
des chercheurs qui ont écrit cet article
le black hills institute c'est une
compagnie privée qui revendent des
fossiles c'est notamment eux qui ont
trouvé préparer et revendu le squelette
du tyrannosaure sioux et le squelette du
tyrannosaure stan qui vient juste de se
vendre la 31 millions de dollars et et
des brouettes donc ce qu'ils peuvent
dire à propos de nano tyrannus c'est
peut-être intéressés savent c'est
peut-être aussi pour arriver à revendre
certains de leurs spécimens sous le nom
d'un autre anus il ya peut-être conflit
d'intérêts voilà donc le black hills
institute a répondu à cet article en
disant non non on n'est pas d'accord
pour des raisons qu'il présente dans cet
article c'est des raisons très
techniques jeu
mettant dessus mais voilà il ya des pour
beaucoup de raisons qu'il présente dans
cet article il considère que non il n'y
a pas de preuves suffisantes que nano
tyrannus c'est un juvénile de
tyrannosaurus donc c'est des débats qui
sont encore tout chaud tout récent qui
enflamme encore la communauté
scientifique donc à la défense de mike
bird on peut pas être au courant de tous
en particulier dans un débat qui va
aussi vite et qui a lieu entre experts
et surtout on peut pas comprendre
absolument tous les arguments moi même
j'ai pas la prétention de comprendre
absolument tous les arguments qui sont
présentés mais dans le cas de
particuliers de de tricératops et de
torosaurus c'est particulièrement
palpable
parce que rien que l'année dernière par
exemple au congrès de la sbp i qui a eu
lieu à brisbane en australie
il y a eu une présentation par l'équipe
qui deux bases avaient proposé que
tricératops et torosaurus c'était la
même chose
cette équipe a cette fois fait une
présentation où il disait ben ce coup là
on n'a pas regardé que la tête on a
aussi regardé les eaux des membres donc
on a coupé dans les humérus et les
fémurs et tout ça et là on a vu des
cercles de croissance concentriques donc
comme sur sur un arbre sauf que ces
cercles de croissance
eh ben ils étaient très très proches les
uns des autres
chez les tricératops de grande taille
et ça ça veut dire que les tricératops
de grande taille ne grandissait plus et
s'il est si les tricératops de grande
taille ne grandissent plus bas ils
auront du mal à grandir pour atteindre
la taille de torosaurus donc ça veut
dire que les tricératops de grande
taille sont des tricératops adultes donc
c'est cette équipe même qui a fait une
présentation en dix ans maintenant qu'on
regarde les membres de tricératops bas
on se demande réellement ce qui se passe
parce qu en fait on n'a pas l'impression
que tricératops pouvait grandir plus que
les adultes qu'on pouvait observer
jusqu'à présent donc ça semblerait clore
le débat encore que il faut toujours
tenir compte du fait que la tête
elle est notamment la collerette avait
l'air de continuer à se remodeler même
chez les tricératops adultes ça ça reste
complètement valides comme observations
donc
voyez il faut c'est vraiment un débat
qui est complètement en train de se
faire en ce moment même parmi les
spécialistes
donc j'ai envie de dire à max bird merci
d'avoir parlé de ceux de ça parce que ça
met un débat de spécialistes sur le
devant de la scène même si pour le coup
il y aurait peut-être fallu le présenter
comme un débat sera était peut-être plus
prudents et puis peut-être tout aussi
intéressant mais comme je le disais en
quatre minutes
c'est pas possible de passer sur tous
les arguments des spécialistes donc
c'est vachement bien d'avoir présenté le
fun fact qui est que peut-être
tricératops et torosaurus c'est la même
chose peut-être que ce dinosaure qu'on
connaît si bien qu'ils s'appellent
tricératops n'existe pas finalement et
ça c'est super cool d'avoir présenté ça
comme un fun fact parce que maintenant
vous avez cette émulsion qui se passe
sur internet avec les gens qui débattent
qui discutent bon alors qu ils
s'engueulent un petit peu aussi sur un
débat qui finalement est en train
d'avoir lieu parmi les spécialistes et
n'est toujours pas fini parce que le
truc dont je viens de vous parler ce
n'est même pas encore publié par les
spécialistes et si ça se trouve ils vont
encore faire de nouvelles découvertes
entre deux là au moment où je publie
cette vidéo entre deux îles vont faire
de nouvelles découvertes qui vont
finalement les faire revenir en arrière
sur leur décision qui sait voilà c'est
tant que c'est pas publier ces ya rien
de graver dans le marbre
et même une fois que c'est publié s'est
toujours pas gravé dans le marbre
puisque comme je les dis c'est ce sont
des hypothèses qui sont très très dur à
vérifier qu'ils sont quasiment
invérifiable autant dire que torosaurus
est tricératops ou que torosaurus n'est
pas tricératops donc il y aura jamais je
pense de vraies grosses réponse
affirmative mais un jour il ya peut-être
un consensus qui va s'installer autour
de toutes ces preuves qui auront été
présentés pendant 10 15 20 années de
débats et c'est comme ça que la science
marche et grâce à mike byrd bas j'ai
l'occasion de vous l'expliquer
maintenant donc merci max bird
ce sera tout pour moi je vous dis à très
bientôt sur notre chaîne
ciao